il est avec nous en direct docteur
patrick bellemare bonsoir dr bellemare
bonjour monsieur roy quand vous dites on
y arrive très bien est ce à dire que la
plupart des gens dont qui passe par un
sacré coeur il y en à quoi une centaine
de patients alités actuellement là et on
a un peu plus d'une centaine dans mon
environnement de travail des soins
critiques ont un peu plus d'une
vingtaine de patients dont la plupart
s'en sortent
évidemment il ya une question de
comorbidité là-dedans ailleurs il ya des
plis patients qui sont passés aux soins
intensifs certains ne survivront pas
leur séjour mais pour la plupart des
codes qu'on a vu à date c'est des gens
qui étaient porteurs de comorbidité
important qui avait d'autres problèmes
de santé très important
puis très souvent ça finit très bien
mais j'ai fait les gens deviennent
extrêmement malade
vous dites les gens deviennent
extrêmement malade est ce que le
portrait le même que ce qu'on disait au
début ça faisait les gens spitz alizés
c'est des gens plus âgés et qui ont un
autre un autre maladie sous jacente
on a vu puisque beaucoup de gens qui ont
été infectés à la coved on a vu toute
une gamme de présentation je te dirai
des gens qui sont les plus susceptibles
de ne pas survivre et puisque là que la
littérature de montrer déjà puisqu'on a
vu dans nos moeurs c'est que les gens
qui ont tendance à moins survie chez les
gens qui sont les plus âgés et plus
malade et qui ont plusieurs maladies
concomitante mes mains les gens qui sont
hospitalisés on a vu dans tout les bras
quête d'argent je vous dirais qu'ils
étaient entre 30 et 65 ans on a beaucoup
de patients certaine ces patients là
deviennent très malade mais récupère ok
c'est ça donc c'est la morbidité
l'acquis et qui va beaucoup dépendre de
6,1 autres maladies sous jacentes mais
quelqu'un même d'assez relativement en
forme peut se retrouver avec ce virus là
à l'hôpital oui à l'hôpital et dans
quelques cas aux soins intensifs
si c'est vrai pour la copie mais c'est
également un vrai dans le cas d'autres
infections à chaque année on a la grippe
saisonnière pirlo patients dont certains
qui sont plutôt jeunes et en bonne santé
qui vont avoir une forme très grave de
l'infection est également pour la cabine
puis la particularité pour l'aco vide
c'est que compte tenu de du très très
très grand nombre de corps on a une
population de gens qui sont extrêmement
malade puis ce lot viennent chez nous on
a vu depuis plusieurs jours le drame
dans certains sièges à celle des pour ce
qui est de l'hôpital vous étiez
manifestement bien préparer mieux
équipée est ce que ça va ce niveau-là
l'équipement personnel est-ce que vous
avez ce dont vous avez besoin
à date oui et par même temps il faut
comprendre que notre effort or pour se
préparer les yeux un travail d équipe
absolument phénoménale aller interne
puis des fois ce type de reportage là
nous montre pour au combien tout le
monde s'est investi mais vraiment tout
le monde et puis dans chez nous ça a été
le cas l'autre tous les corps de
profession ont été mis à contribution
pour adapter l'infrastructure ville
hôpital à un ennemi qu'on connaissait
mal à plusieurs égards on était mieux
équipés que les partenaires d'éden
pendant les 100 de longue durée puis
dans les chu celle des actuellement on
arrive à bien faire face à la crise qu
en même temps qu une bonne quantité de
patience est ce que ça reflète la charge
hospitalière actuelle qu'est ce qui se
passe dans les 6 h et celle des reflète
également la charge
à l'heure actuelle une partie du petit
hôtel de chisinau qui dans les autres
hôpitaux de la région
oui patrick bellemare d'accablement vous
vous demandiez sous aliette à la hauteur
en tout cas ce qui est clair avec ce
qu'on voit c'est que la réponse est un
oui net est retentissant merci de ce que
vous faites et à la prochaine
un merci et vous puis merci à la
populaire si on donne heureusement très
heureusement la population québécoise a
été au rendez-vous pyrite et s'est prêté
à une spleen inédite puisque tu es la
différence
merci dr bellemare à la prochaine au
revoir